let's talk about policies that uh we
don't want we have this
story from the daily mail exclusive it's
become an
outdoor psychiatric ward how
california's scenic venice beach has
become a homeless hot spot with tent
cities
violent crime and rampant drug use
pushing families and tourists out
i'm not even sure i can show any of the
photos because you might get in trouble
on here
but you can see that for a lot of
reasons it's just be
wow wow wow wow that's all i can say i
was i was in venice only a few years ago
i skated the skatepark there all the
time you got these before and after 2015
and 2021
you swipe across tent cities
something doesn't work in california
their policies are just a disaster
and it's unfortunate because you know
northern california is very different
from the big cities in california
and when most people talk about
california they're not talking about the
you know the farming territories and the
you know
counties in the east they're talking
about la and san francisco maybe
sacramento the bay area
even san diego's got i think they still
have a republican mayor but their
policies don't work
whatever this is there's a there's a
recall now for gavin newsom
what you see in places like california
will be coming
to many more places in this country if
these policies expand
so if uh pennsylvania ends up going
democrat
they're just going to keep burning the
place down it's going to it's going to
become more and more like this
i mean you're right i mean california
has been under
a uniparty role democrat rule for how
long now
30 40 50 years i mean something
republican before like what 1991 or 92
yeah yeah and so i i yeah i i think that
there is a direct correlation between
you know this new new progressive
democrat views
in entrenched poverty in places like
california drug use and high crime
right and but people keep voting for it
i mean in some places
in some places you know and i think
pennsylvania is one of those places that
you know in 2022 you know pennsylvania
has a lot of independence that i think
are going to have buyer's remorse that
that
perhaps believed joe biden uh wasn't
moderate not their fault the media
portrayed him
as a moderate uh and big tech censored
stories that were negative about him and
so you saw that poll of like
you know how what percentage of people
would have voted differently had they
known the hundred bucks i mean that that
that alone like an average of what six
percent six for six or seven percent of
people yeah would not have voted for joe
biden now they've known that story
and and like big tech totally censored
it
they they censored one of the one of the
oldest newspapers in the country so it's
not like it was like it was it was a
newspaper that they censored
so so i yeah i i think that that it but
i think that there's gonna be a lot of
independence and i think there's even
gonna be some moderate democrats saying
whoa this is not what i bargained for
and so
you you know me i'm an idealist when it
comes to this country
uh i think it it can be saved um
with the right candidates with the right
message and the ability to articulate
and willingness to go
to the places uh where you need to build
bridges
you know and that's what we're trying to
do in pennsylvania what's your history
like politically what
what did you affiliate as in your 20s
and i've always been i've always been
conservative you know
i don't know if you've ever seen that
movie legends of the fall no only clips
everyone on the show is like what
parnell watched legends of the fall
yeah i watched it once when i when i was
younger but like i i have a lot of
i have a lot of libertarian uh
libertarian
uh you know friends oh
i don't like the government i don't
think that they run things efficiently
and if you don't believe me like
let me think of an example like cash for
clunkers remember that like they come
with an awesome program right they ran
out of cash in a month the government
does not remember remember
the obamacare website remember when
obama gave all those guns to the cartels
yeah i don't oh and can i can i also say
something
you know you know classic classical
liberalism right
after the vietnam wars really i think
was when it was born was
all based on critical thinking and
mistrust of the government right
classical liberalism is like what found
in this country well sure
sure of course of course of course but
in the wake of
in the wake of the vietnam war like if
the government told you
to eat white bread you know most
liberals were like no i mean wheat bread
just because the government told you but
somewhere but somewhere along the way
there's been a shift on the left from
the sort of classical liberalism and
tolerance
uh uh uh and diverse set of ideals to
believing
everything the government says hook line
and center with no critical thinking
just you gotta not be a conservative
that's it
so even now when fauci is like you can
take off your masks if you're vaccinated
they're like no
no because then people will think i'm a
conservative who who cares
what is that their whole identity is
built upon hating somebody that's it
it's like what are your politics i just
hate that guy
is that it that's right that's that's
part of the reason why that's part of
the reason why
you know i i think it's very important
to be a happy warrior right because you
know as if you're running a campaign
you know one of the things you have to
do is draw a contrast right give people
a choice right and i think one of the
ways i think the radical left today's
day and age
they're pretty unhappy they're unhappy
and they i feel like they're unhappy a
lot but
and i'll tell you this in the past year
two years
we have seen the biggest
de-radicalization
of the left that we've probably ever
seen in this country
i'm pretty impressed so a lot of people
i knew from occupy wall street the
anti-fa far leftists
they're cheering for major
pharmaceutical companies they're
cheering for the fbi and the government
and i'm like i see their posts i'm i'm
not kidding like antifa types
saying like yay fbi you go get giuliani
and i'm like
i'm glad to see that you've reformed
your ways and you're pro federal
government
and they're like well i mean it's
different now because they're going
after people i like and i'm like yeah so
you like the fbi right like that that's
cool
i remember when you thought they were
bad and wanted to like you know you
hated the government and we're
protesting all the time
now you're now you're cheering for the
government now you're cheering for the
massive multinational massive
multinational
pharmaceutical company so hey good for
you you know i thought you were kind of
off the deep end
they don't they don't they don't seem to
self-reflect 10 years ago they're like
monsanto bad these big pharmaceutical
companies are evil now they're like yay
which team are you on
yeah well um i you know yeah
i think that's why the republican party
ha they've got a tremendous opportunity
right i just i think that
you know gosh president trump uh
he brought about a a massive
shift in the republican party especially
in pennsylvania right
where in in the span of four years
the republican party has has become less
the part i mean
in fact probably not at all at this
point the party of large corporations
to the party of the working man and and
woman
like that the shift is like unbelievable
yeah the democrats are the party of the
elites
and the college professors and the
hollywood people and the highest
income earners in the country have been
demanding for four years the working
class pay off
all of their debts yes and we're to the
point now where elizabeth warren bernie
sanders
have entertained stripping the value
from the working class savings to pay
off the debts of the highest investors
in the country
i want you i want everyone to think
about that for two seconds bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren
were in favor of stripping the savings
devaluing the savings
of the working class to pay off the
highest
income earners debts that's absolutely
correct that's college degrees
yes people with college degrees make
substantially more than people without
it
and those people are demanding the poor
pay their bills for them
i mean i'm not all about that that's
wrong that is wrong and that that's
you're a hundred percent correct how was
how was how
have the conservatives moved like uh
they appear to be even
lefter than many of the modern democrats
like
no no joke you've got the the the trump
supporters
many are working class union guys who
want their factories back
and then you've got the the the
university leftists
with their degrees and their hillary
clinton and their hedge funds and their
super pacs
and then you you see the uh the the
neo-cons
lincoln project people joining the
democrats how is it that republi
republicans are are left of the
establishment democrats
they're defending the workers rights not
the democrats the democrats are
stripping away their rights
stripping away the value value giving
money to the bourgeoisie
look that i think the republican party
has to embrace
this this new identity this new
working-class identity these these are
our people these are the people that
built this country right and i think
that we have to
i think that we've got to be there for
them we can't shun them i mean
i mean jim banks had a memo if you've
seen jim banks's memo the working class
memo
that and and basically it is uh
congressman banks is is i think he's
he's great
uh but he's got a memo out there about
the path forward for the republican
party and it's like a
it's like a two-page plan of what the
republican party needs to do to be
successful
it's awesome and we should totally
embrace it you should google it right
now and have a look at it but it's it's
something that we should definitely
look it's a showing up for the people
just uh hey
here's what you do you just uh write
down what ron desantis does
and then just be like what he said he's
coming to pittsburgh tomorrow oh
my
god
he's balanced he's balanced you know
protecting people from
a global pandemic with people's freedom
right
and he's done social media censorship
and social media censorship
yeah he's done a a pretty darn good job
you know
their concerns about what people uh
people question conservatives
his stance on free speech issues like he
may be
opposed to the censorship but it's aimed
mostly at affecting politicians
and then there are some issues around
people's right to free speech i think
relating to israel
that people are concerned about but i
look at you know you i don't just see
like one thing and say flush the baby
out the bathwater i'm like
ronda santos is doing it pretty well
texas is doing pretty well uh too
their their social media bill apparently
is is much much better
and we need to see we need to see more
red states
start having this aggressive legislation
to go after these companies and these
and these things because i'll tell you
florida has this bill that's that's i
believe i believe that descendants may
have already signed it is about to sign
it
which gives protections to individuals
companies news organizations and
politicians when it comes to censorship
however facebook as ian points out could
be like then we're cutting off florida
and if you have a florida ip you can't
access the service anymore
sure then what happens in west virginia
tennessee texas arkansas mississippi
georgia
they all start lining up with the exact
same legislation okay then facebook only
exists in new york and california how
about that no they wouldn't want that
that would destroy the company so they
would say okay fine you win
we'll stop censoring conservatives you
know
one of the biggest problems that i have
with politics right now
is that i mentioned conservatives many
republicans seem to be more concerned
about the opinion of the new york times
than their constituents like they're
more worried than your times will say
about them than their own constituents
yeah you you look at what the media says
and they lie every single day
they say there is no bias against
conservatives and i'm like
but you're the one it was gizmodo that
broke the first story one of the first
that facebook was censoring conservative
news outlets now they changed their tune
because they realized
it's a good thing these these
journalists who first reported it were
like oh look what i found then they were
like no no no we like that they're
censoring these ideas because then
people can't have them if they don't
share the ideas they won't know so keep
them ignorant keep them in the dark
train them like mushrooms you know you
feed them crap and you keep them in the
dark so
now you're gonna start seeing a lot of
states hopefully start picking this up
i'm stoked when i look at the past 10
years and i see how many states have
adopted constitutional carry
fantastic it's remarkable i didn't even
realize that in the 80s
you couldn't even get a concealed carry
permit in most states it was like may
issue they tell you to screw off
now it's constitutional carry you walk
in you pass a background check
you walk out with a gun and you can be
carrying it concealing it whatever
fantastic protecting people's rights
let's see the same thing across the
board at the state level
the states need to start passing these
laws local is where it's at yeah
yes yes i would also say that i think
it's
it's very the states that do the best
have a great communication between their
federal office holders the governor
and the state legislatures right so i
think yes yes i think
a governor can have an unbelievable
power if he's got a legislature that's
willing to work with him they can get a
lot of things done and bring about
profound positive change
in in people's lives i think you take
that to the next level
where you've got a governor that's
communicating seamlessly with
like a senator congress congressmen or
women uh
and and everything is is working like a
smoothly oiled machine that's how you do
it and that that's really what
we're trying to do in pennsylvania with
regards to uniting the republican party
both uh in washington d.c as a liaison
as
a candidate for senate as a liaison to
the federal government
but also working hand in glove with
those state representatives who are
boots on the ground
in their communities every day and
making sure our messaging is on point
our organizing is on point our
fundraising is on point and we're
advocating for policies that are the
best for
all of pennsylvania at every level right
i'm concerned that uh just the
fragmentation of the u.s is getting too
severe
you know when you look at these cities
they got rising crime they have ongoing
riots
and they just for whatever reason you
get more far leftists in
and then i can only imagine that in the
red areas people are are separating each
other you know like
how many people have moved to texas
recently tons of personalities that are
conservative are
fleeing to texas so tax is going to
become increasingly more red
the blue areas will become increasingly
more blue and then there's going to be
no real overlap i think so i think
there's some people that would say that
there are leftists moving from
california to texas
and that's why people are worried about
texas turning blue right there's this
whole texas turning blue movement
so that's why people are leaving uh
people were leaving
states where they voted in democrat uh
democrat leadership for 30 years and
then going and essentially voting the
same way in in texas and
and i don't think texas is going to is
going to turn blue but people always
talk about it
i think now it won't because people who
are fleeing texas are conservative or at
least opposed the democrats
they saw a huge rise in homeless in
austin
yeah certainly i mean it might just be
everywhere in all these metropolitan
cities but evictions are starting up i
think in two months because the
moratorium was ended
in texas everywhere so we we were on the
verge of looking at like millions upon
millions of evictions
they said on sixth street in austin it's
just like tent city
and in california not just in venice in
california in l.a there's i'll tell you
up and down you know i heard something
scary what streets
it's a video rumor going around that the
u.s government is threatening subsidies
of farmers
so there's a thing i think it's called
following where they're basically paid
not to grow food
yeah and so there's a concern right now
that because of the shortages and
everything's happening and the
how the tax subsidies work that we have
like we're like eight months out from
some
serious food shortages i wouldn't be
surprised
the the idea that you can just stop an
economy dead in its tracks
and then snap your fingers and get it
back going again no the workers are
displaced
what would be the end state for that
like how could that possibly be a good
thing like i haven't heard no i'm not
saying i'm not saying it's a good thing
i'm not saying anybody wants to do it
i'm saying that why would the federal
government want to do it the system by
which we have
subsidies for farmers has created a
circumstance based on having that's
happened
which is contributing to gotcha the
probability of more so there's already
food shortages
about people i guess you're not seeing
at the national you're not seeing
national news but if you look at these
local news outlets they're talking about
food shortages
now there's rumors that the supply chain
disruption
the rising fuel costs have made
everything substantially harder
workers are displaced because of the
pandemic many moved they're not going to
go back to those jobs
right people don't realize that the
shortage we're seeing for like computer
chips
what do you think is going to happen
with food like do you think that
food is immune from the shortages we're
experiencing the economy no
no and no in fact it's the the supply
the logistics chain is is real
right and you look at the look look at
the cost of of food and and how much
people are paying for certain things
it's it's
it is absolutely concerning and my my
fear
is that you know because i mean we're
seeing inflation now
you know i think i think that i think
the federal government like
they're not going to hard default on on
our on our debt right i do think
they're going to print their way out our
debt and deficit issues are the biggest
the greatest leadership challenge that
my generation of leaders are
going to face right it's a big deal
we've got to figure out what to do with
our debt and deficit but
you know we're not going to hard default
on our debt but i do think what what
the plan is is is a soft default which
is to purposefully inflate our currency
so that the value of our debt
is worth less right and and and
i think that's what you're seeing right
now and i think that's what you're
talking to right now and
my fear is that we are on the brink of
now i mean
we're on the brink of what could be a
recession
i think a year from now you know um
and and and hopefully hopefully we can
pull ourselves out of it but
like we really have to start advocating
for pro-growth economic policies like
right away we really have to start i
don't know what i don't
i don't know how you fix this man the
the train it's a freight train
on the tracks and then they just stopped
it and then all the carts flew up in the
air from the inertia and just scattered
all over
and now they're like all right set the
train up again and you're like bro one
cart like rolled down the mountain it's
in the ocean i don't even know how to
get that back up here yeah
so when they shut down the economy and
that this idea that you could just start
it up again
was is ludicrous let's say you've got 10
employees making 16 bucks an hour at a
restaurant
economy shuts down these people who are
in their early 20s decide to move back
home they go to the suburbs to stay with
their parents
okay start the economy back up
restaurant goes we don't have any
employees
we have to rehire everybody to start
without any money food all spoiled
you can't just do it we just spent an
entire week going all across the state
talking to business owners from erie
down to south philly and they've all had
that problem
it is not imaginary and and nobody wants
to work when you're getting paid more
not to work
yeah and you're right like they're
having issues uh both in shipping and
logistics and food processing and
finding
finding truck drivers and the cost of
fuel has made it more difficult on truck
drivers to get from point a to point b
i mean there there are issues at every
level i mean again i think
i think it can be saved uh but it's
gonna take
leadership and focus and clear
clear communication clear honest
communication with the american people
which
you know uh is not uh joe biden's strong
suit
um so you know look that's that's why
it's so important that's why it's so
important to win in 2022 that's why the
slogan
is win pennsylvania save america thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you